sweet moses of the red sea anchorman is
back you might be thinking it was that
line in the original anchorman movie but
no no
i'm just that good
anchorman 2 the legend continues i am
glad that the legend kept continuing
because i [ __ ] loved this film here's
what i gotta say [ __ ] everything people
are saying negative about this film like
oh it's a little bit totally uneven it's
not structured so well
all that [ __ ] here's what matters when
you go to watch a movie like [ __ ]
anchorman do you laugh are you gonna
laugh are you gonna snicker
are you gonna chuckle or are you gonna
laugh
every time i do that laugh i start to
cough really bad
i need to cut back on the weed i'm ron
burgundy i love ron so much yeah that's
right
if you're a fan of the show you know
what's coming next
i'm gonna suck robin burgundy's penis
and it's gonna be a delight we're gonna
have a ball of a tie there'll be
princesses fairies and elves and they
will be celebrating in the harmony of
fellatio i know it's just an okay
impression but you know i'm getting
there i'm getting it anyway will
ferrell's back and he's just so
comfortable with this role if you've
seen the first anchorman and you loved
it you're still gonna love it you just
still want to hang out with ron and paul
rudd you know he's if i had to complain
about this movie i'd say that like paul
rudd is kind of just a normal dude in
this one he was more defined in the
first one but he's kind of just a really
laid back guy but you know paul rudd is
still [ __ ] funny he still has that
thing about him you know he's sarcastic
and
you know he's sincere at the same time
it's like it's like a perfect mix of
sincereness and sarcasm it's
it's really interesting there's to be
ant-man yeah that's gonna be so [ __ ]
cool
if only i knew who the [ __ ] that man was
steve carell is brick everyone i meet
now just [ __ ] hate steve carrell for
some reason but i think steve carell is
still hilarious sure some of his movies
can get pretty annoying but when he
strikes gold he strikes gold i really
liked him as brook they gave him a [ __ ]
ton more scenes and he is like
ridiculously over the top it's insane
just how like amplified and hyper this
guy is you start to get concerned for
him same time you trust him i'm not
entirely sure how people are going to
respond to brick but i thought he was
hilarious and um
champ
never learned this actor's name didn't
really care too much for him in the
first one honestly he didn't really make
me laugh that much but in this one he
actually had me cracking up a few times
way to go champ
whammy all i cared about when i saw this
film because anchorman is one of my
favorite films of all time am i gonna
just have a good time hanging out with
these guys again i know it's not going
to be able to top the first one i just
want to
hang out with these dudes and it's cool
because three out of four of them are
really famous now poor champ so before
when like steve crow and paul rudd
weren't as well known and i think
anchorman's role that made him a movie
star now it's like a decade later and
gonna have these celebrities in there
and champ so yeah i said a great time i
felt more like a hangout vibe you know
because you could really feel these
actors doing a lot of improv together
these guys you could tell were just
having a really good time being together
there's a lot of great supporting roles
in there you got harrison ford it was
kind of funny seeing harrison ford in it
because he they do give him like
over-the-top stuff to do christina
applegate is back i like what they did
with her role they didn't just like
kick her out of the film and just
explain what happened in one sentence
like they made her a serious important
part of this film even though she's not
really advertising the trailer you
shouldn't know that remember how i'm
married with children
i would masturbate to her so much
maybe i'll do it again tonight and james
martin i'd probably say he's my favorite
supporting character who's a famous guy
in this movie like he either no one else
could have played this role that
charming kind of swaggish old school
thing about him yes yes and there's just
so many incredible cameos in this it's
loaded with cameos man loaded with
cameos i'm gonna give them all away for
you right now first cameo i'm just
[ __ ] with you i wouldn't actually do
that i would be such a douchebag if i
did that look here's the point you're
going there to [ __ ] laugh right so
are you gonna laugh are you gonna have a
good time yes and that's all that counts
it's the funniest movie i've seen all
year i was filled with joy i was moved
by the sound of laughter i was laughing
like the greek god zeus making love to
the woman who would one day give birth
to hercules that woman was amelia
earhart by the way who zeus may love to
that's what happened when she got lost
let me get straight to the point here
all in all i gotta say anchorman two got
it super right
all right guys thanks for checking out
my review for anchorman2 why don't you
go ahead scroll that comment box below
and tell me
did you enjoy anchorman two i should
really prepare these questions before i
do this and if you wanna see more
episodes straight to the point click
link right here
watch my [ __ ] and last but not least if
you wanna get updated every time one of
my reviews or videos is out go and click
on this button about my dig to subscribe
that's right
click the dick and you subscribe
simple as that only you can see my
genitals right now
i'm actually in my underwear
why
because it's youtube
it's just a [ __ ] camera at me
i can do whatever i want
because i
have that power let me tell you
when this little legend continues
and by continues i mean you know second
go-around you can have sex for a second
time you might need to give me like two
hours i'll show you one hell of a time
take it a pleasure island mount you like
a s
steer horse they make love to you like a
bear
in tijuana like eating cheese off the
body
of angelina jolie's husband brad pitt
those jokes were legend wait for it
dairy